hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the water war challenged
by J foul J Palin hey pal hey pal Oh
Jimmy Fallon yeah okay so we're playing
the water war chalice basically if you
played war in your cards we've put a
card over whoever has the highest wins
whoever the lowest though it's most
important because they lose and the
person with the highest card gets to
dump these are our lives I can as
they're filled with ice water not really
nice anymore because it's hot out here
but they're cold water that's why we're
gonna dump them on the person we're here
with team edge and we're gonna play you
guys ready I'm ready
all right one two three baby Mesa won
races hi okay wallet Paper Scissors bed
Rock Paper Scissors shoot
okay it's your deal all right go chose
the same right face man yeah I got I got
my dog my buck oh that was cool like a
for fur all right ready
one two three Oh Joker the Joker gets to
dump on whoever he's filled
yeah just jump on whoever the tricky
decision uh-huh is it is it is it is it
really cold one two three flip mama yeah
by seven what is with the setup
continually whoever
I mean blush you know this happened last
time okay you're dead you dead to me
Yeah right amazing team edges solidify
for their buddy
oh you're dead to me it was a one two
three all right oh there is ah damn it
yeah hey Fred boogaloos knew him all
right bring it over and bring it over
wait why are you so pleased we're having
great on this side of the table right
ready
what yeah oh yeah three two
Matt you got one in your mouth yeah
we're right away oh one two three oh oh
oh sorry shuffle Oh dad always we all
use your bad dish you doing slow okay
ready all right one two three oh that is
right that is yeah that is house fishes
Oh doesn't it pull baby pulling one car
now three do what yeah
while going cool three do what you did
that on purpose good shirt back of the
shirt ready three dude one what is this
are you - what did we lose everybody -
Marlon the luck of the draw I'm over
there yeah you just said it's like the
draw I feel amazing or you're learning
hockey fill it up ah your remix of those
sounds ah this is another guy you watch
me shuffle two times ahead
three what oh come there we go dang it I
lost ready yeah yeah dang it there goes
my face card but okay yeah ready
how come my she'll give you a merciful
death no one I am right three two one no
go yes
work it if you do three flip dad I know
you all yeah we haven't gotten in yet
yeah remember how evil Rico suave are
there you'll get me there's a lot of
water in this this cup is really full
not ready beans one two three what are
you a boy scout yeah silk is baloney
Rodney Lough larkey Brian every time huh
Brian guy you can excuse me I thought
you already did some mercy worked out
doubt whatever rhyme at 12.30 Baker's
family feel this for generations to come
what Oh No
Chinese water torture ready set go dang
yeah I lose this is it for me that's it
goodbye goodbye I love you all ah ah I
thought it was done wait I read it's
gonna matter
oh I'm gonna be - yeah right right yeah
course ready you really set himself up
for that one what everyone if it was uh
brought here - yeah that water smells
yeah that's it without alerting
well anyway yes that was water war thank
you so much for watching and thank you
for joining us teammate it's not over
though yeah I've had me with a water
balloon oh it was the first owners
content 3 2 1 fire
okay so that was the end of water war
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you deem it for having us over and
look on their channel for another video
of this action coming at you real soon
thanks again everybody see you in the
next one bye